what is a computer well before the
concept of computers people wanted
machines that could complete human tasks
often referred to as an atomic on some
of these automatic mechanisms were
designed to seem arise for reasons of
entertainment or intimidation but some
were designed for more practical
concerns mechanisms that could imitate
human tasks in order to save time though
a core question emerges when we think of
machines that imitate human action where
does humaneness reside many believed are
humaneness resided in our Faculty of
reason Aristotle was famous for reducing
human reason to a mechanism via a
process called deduction that is shown
to be the logical conclusion of a series
of existing statements people agree on
and he marks a philosophical shift
towards a clockwork view of human reason
his ideas were the foundation on which
the study of logic was built and in the
1660s a boy in his early teens named
Gottfried Leibniz was introduced to
Aristotle's logic by one of his school
teachers he points to this moment when
describing what he called his great idea
instead of automating physical work he
dreamed of automating the work of human
minds mechanizing thought although he
never achieved this dream live Anna's
went on to mechanize an important
conceptual task of his day calculation
inspired by pedometers which could count
rotary motion
he built a mechanical device that could
do addition subtraction multiplication
and division
and this heralded a new era of machines
that could perform conceptual work
through mechanization and around this
time a global industry was starting to
emerge based on the creation and sharing
of material goods at a much larger scale
this was accomplished by moving from
craft production one person doing one
thing
to mass production in factories many
people working together to make lots of
one thing this era is known as the
Industrial Revolution and it led to a
very pragmatic problem how to make lots
of things faster Adam Smith a British
economist and philosopher of this time
was well known for the concept of
division of labor
it's simple but very powerful to do this
the task of making something was broken
down into a predetermined sequence of
steps each step in the process is given
to a different person
the powerful insight Smith had was that
no matter what you are making having say
10 people each working on a different
task to make one thing is always faster
than each person performing all the
tasks to make it individually since each
person is working on a smaller specific
task this person would stay in one frame
of mind or context and wouldn't waste
time switching from one task to another
this procedural view of tasks Smith had
we now refer to as an algorithm this
algorithmic view of manufacturing
changed factories forever ultimately it
leads to a world where human work
becomes more and more machine-like but
also it allowed machines to become more
human-like and this leads to a very
famous insight if humans are just
following algorithms then what's to stop
them from being mechanised completely
this is an idea which drove Charles
Babbage who was a mechanically minded
mathematician who was fascinated by Adam
Smith's ideas of breaking up tasks and
Natta meeting them and Babbage takes the
next big step after Lebanese in terms of
mechanizing conceptual work the
multi-step calculations to solve unknown
values known as algebra and it's
essential to realize that algebra is a
powerful tool because it's the link
between the physical world and the
symbolic one
imagine for example soap manufacturer
wants to make a travel-size soap so he
needs to divide the regular sized box
into smaller equally sized boxes and so
let's convert this physical situation
into algebra by letting X represent the
side length of the big box so the volume
of the big box is x times X times X or X
cubed and we are saying it must be equal
to 2 times the volume of the smaller box
let's call the side of the smaller box Y
and now we have an algebraic
representation of the situation so to
answer any question of the form given
this box what's the side length of the
smaller boxes we just rearrange the
equation to isolate y so that Y is a
function of X and plug in the value of x
to get Y algebra allows us to build
statements known as polynomials about
the real world and solve them in a
mechanical way but at the time algebra
was a human job people manually wrote up
big books called tables of values which
for a single function lists all possible
questions or values of X on one side and
all results values of Y on the other and
as soon as Babbage actually started
producing these tables for the
Astronomical Society in England he was
famous for saying I wish to god these
calculations could be done by steam and
that problem led to one of his great
mechanical designs a machine that could
do algebra known as his Difference
Engine specifically the operator would
take some polynomial that needed solving
and input the first few values of the
table by setting a sequence of wheels
and when they turned the crank the
machine performed a cascade of additions
and subtractions and step through each
value of x one at a time and printed the
results
completely automating a once complex and
time consuming human job but his
Difference Engine followed one specific
algorithm this procedure was baked into
the mechanics of the machine itself and
this led to Babbage's final most
ambitious dream a machine that can
automate any algorithm known as his
analytic engine and he envisioned his
machine as follows first an algorithm is
dreamed up by a human and then written
down on a series of punch cards which
held each instruction whatever these
instructions are they would be fed into
the machines central drum and then the
machine would follow your instructions
and this leads to an interesting
question what does his analytic engine
actually need to be able to do well he
realized that no matter what your
algorithm is it's really just some
well-defined sequence of doing and
deciding and in terms of what the
Machine actually does at any step his
calculation so his machine had a
subsystem which he called the mill that
could perform basic operations of logic
and or and not and arithmetic and in
terms of deciding the machine also
needed to be able to recognize commands
of the form if something then something
known as a conditional statement so that
based on any given calculation the next
operation can take different paths or
branches lastly the machine needed to be
able to remember intermediate values
during computation so he included a
memory which could hold 10,000 40 digit
numbers and it would output the results
on a roll just as his Difference Engine
did and with that calculation branching
and memory he had everything he needed
for the machine to follow any algorithm
you can think of what's most important
is that he fully decoupled the algorithm
from the machines mechanism
and that's what a computer is a machine
that can automate any algorithm and this
is when computer science is born when
the program becomes the machine so the
intelligence of the machine was put into
the hands of the person writing the
algorithm the program although is
analytic engine was never actually built
what he designed on paper was equivalent
to a modern computer but way ahead of
its time up until now people had
understood machines as doing the thing
they were designed to do and programming
just wasn't something the public
understood however one of his protegees
a young Gaeta Lovelace was famous for
recognizing the more general power his
machine held she realized the rules the
analytic engine follow were only limited
to your imagination how you programmed
it she famously noted that the machine
could solve abstract mathematical
functions but it could just as well be
outputting music that is the numbers
coming out of the machine could
represent anything and very soon this
idea would take root before and it leads
to some interesting questions what can't
we do
with a well-defined sequence of
instructions what's out of reach of a
mechanical process
you